all right cool cool cool and we go
live all right citizens of the reject Nation you
know what to do as always let us know if we are
live my friends it is Coy and I today uh we got
a lot to talk about um but before we you know
hop into everything and and start breaking things
down here and start you know kind of chewing the
bones and whatnot just let us know that y'all
are here let us know that you can see and hear
us because uh otherwise we'll just be talking
into the void uh which you know is fun but uh
you know it's it's not good entertainment for
the rest of you guys so uh so yeah live I see
it Jonathan Davidson wonderful uh nerdy wave
Chay Jamari Middleton TS Funk 2005 uh awesome
to see you all here I wish we were talking on
a more you know upbeat circumstance um but yeah
before we hop into this got to you know just let
you guys know a couple of things um first of all
uh uh you know just a disclaimer for YouTube
and for everybody in here viewing uh in the
discussion that we have today um we are you know
we're providing an objective report on the details
that are out and you know probably a little bit
of speculation based on that we are not experts
um but we have been following along to a degree
um so that yeah uh while our conversation today
may involve mature themes and sensitive subjects
and controversial topics uh we are committed to
presenting this information responsibly and uh we
are not going to show any explicit footage chances
are you guys have already seen most of that stuff
and at no point are we going to endorse or promote
hate or violence no matter whose side you maybe
find yourself on in this conflict um and yeah
our aim is basically just to go over the details
in an informative and hopefully maybe somewhat
educational way and uh yeah we'll be adhering
to YouTube's Community guidelines and ensuring
a respectful environment for all you guys um so
yeah it's me and koi today uh due to the schedule
we we're just you know it's the holidays things
are getting crazy over here we have a lot to get
done before Christmas so because a certain company
decided to give us uh screenings for episodes uh
the day before Christmas Eve so that's nice
what who could who could possibly that Bey
I don't know who you're talking about we all want
to work up until the wire we appreciate it so but
yeah normally this would be like a 10 to 15 minute
video uh but today uh we are yeah we're here live
because there's less editing and stuff involved
overall um yeah we obviously as well don't know
as much as the jury knows we haven't been privy
to everything that they had to deliberate over um
but we're going to again do our best to be you
know objective and you know straight with the
facts that are available to us um yeah we don't
you know talk about celebrity trials much here
on this channel we're not a big gossip Channel
but since this this is you know it's Kang it's a
big big part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe they
have you know rested so much on Jonathan major so
yeah it makes we we felt remiss if we didn't at
least address this because you know people were
going to be wondering how this will affect you
know the film industry the thing we do talk about
uh and Marvel in particular which we talk about
a lot and uh just in case you're wondering Greg
is not here today because uh he and his lovely
wife are celebrating their anniversary of their
wedding um so yeah uh you know it's been a year
they deserve a little bit of a rest a little bit
of a break this news broke today and uh and yeah
he still worked he put together a thumbnail put
together thumbnail and and wrangled our you know
he did all the calls he he wrangled us kids he's
now he's done he's sitting yeah so uh yeah and
and he's I mean what really is happening is he's
avoiding having to he's going out for drinks with
you know the rest of the reject Nation he just
doesn't want to do this bending over backwards
he's out there enjoying the pub yeah he just
doesn't want to be you know part of you know a
touchy subject discussion today um but yeah so
we're going to get into this uh obviously there's
a lot to talk about and we want to hear your guys
thoughts as well um so let's go into the main view
look at that whoa hey that's us we're uh in the
little tiny box um but yeah how's it going guys
let us know first and foremost what you think of
the verdict and and of the you know evidence that
you've seen or the details that you have heard um
from my understanding today out of four charges
um which you know um the four charges were assault
aggravated harassment and direct harassment uh
stemming from the 911 call made on March 25th
regarding uh Grace Jabari uh he pleaded not guilty
to all charges and uh Jabari alleged that Majors
caused her injuries during an altercation in a car
there's no footage from inside the car we've seen
some footage from outside the car um but it's my
understanding that today uh Jonathan majers was
found guilty of assault in the third degree uh
essentially recklessly uh uh recklessly causing
physical injury uh but not necessarily with intent
and then uh harassment in the second degree he was
found not guilty of assault in the third degree
with intent to cause injury uh so it seems to
me the intent was the separation between the the
charges I'm not a lawyer between the charges that
actually uh were found guilty versus not guilty is
what I I gathered yeah absolutely so you know the
big question here then becomes yeah the intent uh
the you know premeditated nature of you know the
actions on trial here um and I don't know I mean
I guess before we hop into the nitty-gritty what's
your feeling on this I mean do you have a general
just gut sense or or assessment uh I think I think
it's really hard because there's no version um
there's no reality where we know all the facts
and it's really a trial difficult thing to assess
that and that's why I think the deliberation went
for five hours um because it's always these
trials are always really messy with one side
trying to make the other look as bad as possible
and that's like the nature of how you do trials
uh is you try to make someone you defame someone's
character as far as possible and then you go back
and forth and I think this is a no- win scenario
um because now we basically get uh a woman who who
will always be known as this and a man who will
always be known as this and regardless of either
of their other talents this is just all of the the
details that we'd never have uh otherwise so I'm
glad that it doesn't seem like the premeditated
element um was seen as guilty it doesn't seem like
this was something that was uh a thing that wanted
anyone wanted to happen um it does seem like you
know violence did occur um I don't think I see
a lot I mean the internet's a gross gross place
I'm pretty what do you mean uh but the fact that
you have you know people just immediately on one
side saying well of course he did it and people on
the other side saying uh of course he didn't do it
because there's footage of him running away from
her we don't know anything um so on one side there
is the audio of him basically comparing her to
these you know these really strong powerful women
that was definitely manipulated aggressively to
people like making fun of him for it and yes it's
a silly thing to say uh he was basically you know
saying like I'm a great man I want a great woman
behind me and then that turned into like people
turning him into the a monster about a statement
that wasn't necessarily true but again you try to
defame someone as far as possible then you've got
the footage from running away so everyone assumes
like well he couldn't have done anything wrong
why would he be running but we don't know if you
know he's trying to get away from the situation
because he realized he did something wrong we
don't know and we can never know so this long
rant to basically say what I'm glad of is that
he doesn't seem to be someone who premeditated
attacked her it was something that happened in
the throws of a heated argument and that is what
he's been charged with is something happening in
that moment what I don't love is that you know
it seems to be um an actual act of violence like
this is someone who I really respect as an actor
who who I you know enjoyed the work of quite a
bit so it's always shitty to find out you know
someone you respect and admire uh is capable of
something that has apparently occurred yeah and
and I mean people in the chat are are sounding
off right now basically saying that Marvel has
now officially fired him I'm pulling that up
just to verify um but yeah I mean I I certainly
believe that that I mean would be the next yeah I
mean discussing film has it uh roll oh yep Marvel
yeah Rolling Stones reporting it um deadline yeah
uh I wonder if there's a particular statement but
I mean I guess you could have seen you certainly
would have seen that coming at the very least at
least um and yeah I mean this whole thing to
me has seemed like a a pretty messy situation
because in a different way this almost reminds
me of what happened with Johnny Depp and Amber
herd in the sense that there's clearly I don't
know there's so much really strong opinionation
on both sides of the evidence and obviously all of
us out here the the the Johnny Depp trial was was
majorly you know publicized and we got so many
glimpses into that and there was video and all
that stuff but what seemed to be happening there
was you know regardless of which side you a lot
more of the blame to you have a situation where
it seems like two people are in a toxic situation
that isn't good for the either of them and that's
kind of this just a subjective opinion but that's
kind of the vibe that I have gotten from this thus
far because it doesn't really all of the evidence
I've heard hasn't really made anybody seem
particularly great or shun a light of you know
innocence directly on anybody and I mean I do at
least you know again we're just two people at home
keeping up with the news or whatever but it does
only reporting on it because of the people that
would ask over and over again I'm not thrilled
about this no not where I want to be no I mean
I haven't been sitting here rooting for you know
find him guilty or whatever um I didn't touch the
major I mean you bring up uh Depp and Amber herd I
I intentionally never say anything about that cuz
I think they're both really shitty towards each
other in this case pun intended uh but I don't
think um unless this related to what we do cover
on the channel it's it's any of our business but
this is affecting the business that we do discuss
yeah um but I do think that uh people want to
villainize people I think people get very excited
to feel better than other people so they like to
kick people while they're down so I think that
the the Depp herd uh instance is a great example
of people celebrating awful [__] and um I think
it's gross yeah yeah and I mean you know I find it
interesting that there are still a lot of people
out there who are you know completely on the side
of like oh no he's he's completely innocent he's
framed and and and yeah I mean there's a lot of
evidence that is kind of strange and hinky that
does support some of his side of the story um but
to me just given all the different messages that
we've seen uh you know leaked out and whatnot and
the attitudes on display it certainly seems like
there is some level of toxicity and narcissism at
work here some people in the chat have brought up
um you know some of the abusive behaviors that he
has demonstrated in maybe a controlling fashion
or whatever again through some of these the text
messages were pretty uh awful to read pretty harsh
and and yeah and and I mean not going to get into
all the nitty-gritty details but certainly there
seemed like a bit of a back and forth in terms
of codependency threats of certain kinds of
harm uh that are not the obvious kinds um and
and yeah this seems like a pretty harsh situation
all around to me and I can kind of imagine I mean
it took what was it it was six jurors after four
hours of deliberation over three days a six-person
jury reached a verdict in the trial um he was
accompanied by his attorneys and supported by
his now girlfriend Megan good family members found
guilty of uh two of the charges and acquitted of
two others um so we have till February the 6th
to if he will uh you know be sentenced to jail
time which could be up to one year um but yeah
this this whole thing has really been kind of
harsh and ugly to follow because again I do think
that there is a bit of zealousness to pull one of
your favorite words in basically taking any
hole in the prosecution side as just proof of
complete innocence and I think that's the tricky
and and difficult part of any one of these types
of situations is the fact that to me I'm sitting
here yeah just it's it's as I said before to me
this seems like a toxic ugly situation these two
people maybe shouldn't have been together I'm sure
there were things that Drew them together but you
know here where We've Ended up it seems like it's
brought certain aspects of this person's character
to light and there have been other people and
again it's all heay we don't know there have been
other people who have corroborated at least some
of these manipulative and trolling uh behaviors
from Majors um but yeah the whole thing I I would
agree is is disappointing because I mean yeah it's
been really fun and enjoyable to watch his Star
Rise he's a terrific actor most certainly I'm very
curious to see what happens after this um because
again you know it's uh he's going to be let go of
Marvel at the very least but I wonder with this
amount of you know doubt in the court of public
opinion whether or not uh you know he will be just
completely shunned from Hollywood or whether in
a couple years he'll start popping up in certain
things again all uh any number of people who have
been canell out of society um and I mean that's a
good question uh s s's guitar I hope I said your
name right just will like I'll put it to you guys
in the chat you know after all this is said and
done if he serves whatever time is allotted him
you know would you be back out there searching
out his performances and looking to support his
movies or are you kind of yeah are you sort of
done with them uh from now on and uh and yes
Larry Reed I'm glad you're in here for the real
important questions Rebel Moon uh we we'll have
some thoughts on Rebel moon in a few days don't
even worry um and and I'm curious too because I've
heard it said and I don't know if this is true
but I've heard it said that the Marvel contract
involved a scenario in which only Majors could
play Kang but at the same time now I'm like if
this is if there's a legal cause for dissolution
would they have to stick to that or or anything um
because yeah at least uh at least as of deadline
a studio rep has confirmed that they are not
going to move forward with Majors so do we get a
whole new Kang or do we do the you know rumored
switch over to a Dr Doom or something like that
I think no matter what this kind of establishes
Secret Wars will probably clean up continuity in a
stronger way than it might have originally I think
they're already calling uh King Dynasty Avengers
5 um I think basically it's going to be I mean I
think it was always gonna kind of be Avengers
versus the X-Men I think now it's going to be
Avengers versus the X-Men in a very different way
like a bigger way um I think Deadpool you know is
is not done shooting and it might tweak the third
act a bit as it goes into Secret Wars we always
knew that Deadpool was going to go directly into
Secret Wars I think now it's going to move certain
things up I think uh Doom was always going to
be the one who took over the king the idea was
was always to me obviously that it was going to
be Kang being a whole phase of big bad that Doom
easily usurps and thus making Doom such a powerful
villain that you're like oh my God he took out the
big bad um but now I just assume that's going to
be a little earlier uh I don't think they will
recast Kang necessarily um I think Marvel's in a
really tricky spot because you know Daniel Daniel
Destin keton uh no Destin Daniel Daniel the d uh
I think is uh is off of of Kang Dynasty which is
now Avengers 5 but he is doing shangi 2 but you've
even got things like you know simu having uh you
know Achilles surgery like the Marvel Universe has
been in a really tricky spot because their number
one martial artist got literally Achilles and then
you got you know this horrible situation we've got
so many things um that have up the 10year plan
so I think they're going to how is that spin I'm
giving facts I don't understand people cheering
for anything in this in this there's no good here
yeah and it's interesting to look in the chat
I mean I I feel like we typically have a pretty
positive uh comment section here but I do see a
lot of you know direct support for for Jonathan
Majors but moreover uh some mock like if if we
can discourage one thing I don't want to you
know come in and Mom you guys but let's at least
be respectful even if you don't see any of the
validity of uh of uh what's her name Grace Jabari
if you don't see any side of her story you know
everyone's perspective is their own but let's at
least be respectful in here and let's not fly off
on I saw one comment like oh you can't be a victim
and a strong woman at the same time and there's
only two kinds yes you can and uh this whole thing
is pretty ugly and I would at least encourage you
guys to entertain the idea that we wouldn't be
in this situation completely flippantly or or
at least that's what I hope and I guess anything
can happen but uh let's at least be respectful
of the moment um and yeah regardless of whether
you think Majors belongs in jail or whether you
think he's completely innocent let's at least uh
let's keep it above the level here in the chat if
you want to go off on some other message board
and uh and talk some [__] there are plenty of
people making plenty of videos that are all of
the innan commentary you want there are people
for you people are profiting off this enjoy those
people find your gross little pockets but not here
because that's not what we're doing we're giving
news about a situation that sucks for everyone and
we're talking about how that's going to affects
the thing we do talk about on this channel which
is movies this is the real rejects this isn't the
gossip Channel this isn't TM this isn't we're not
we're trying not to be culture vultures this is
the absolute last thing I wanted to do with my
Monday I don't need to read your Dil it's okay
I mean and and and big love and respect to the
guys in here to all of you guys in here who are
you know keeping it above the level and and you
know being respectful at the very least um and
I mean yeah if we're going to sit in here and
be like ah you know it's the big the big looming
ghoul of feminism go home like there's a lot more
complication to life than simply that and I feel
like if this was a complete flippant thing they
wouldn't have spent as much time as they have uh
you know they wouldn't have spent as much time
as they have corroborating things and you know
the the jury that they got had to deliberate
quite a bit from what I understand and you know
took a good amount of extra time in reviewing
the facts of the case obviously they have more
facts than we do uh so yeah I don't care about
your opinion and uh Eddie tuer you don't matter
to me uh right now he has been found guilty of
uh assault in the third degree and harassment
in the second degree um so that And to clarify
once again that's assault without um uh it's
assault causing Reckless uh injury but not with
the intent to cause injury the ones he was found
not guilty of was the assault in the third degree
with intent and and uh and another aggravated
harassment uh charge so I mean the situation
that that happened in this taxi truck whatever
it is certainly seems like the most dubious uh
because yeah we'll just never see inside that car
we've had the the driver's accounts to deal with
and then you know beyond that we have you know
surveillance videos from the street um but yeah
this whole thing is is is I I would say nuance
and it would at least be good to I think that's
why the trial went the way it did like I think
the reason that it didn't get all four charges
is because it's nuanced I think the reason that
it wasn't completely innocent is because there
are both sides being too a point at fault but
again like I said at the top this is two people
trying to make the other look as bad as possible
because that's the way trials are done yeah and
I mean again at least from where I'm sitting it
doesn't seem like anybody is completely innocent
here and I know that from the accounts and from
again certain conversations we have been Prov to
you know Jonathan Major's uh he's clearly got the
means to defend his status and his reputation and
whatnot and uh I don't know some of these backs
and forths like yeah especially that one that's
been sort of twisted around of him talking about
all the you know sort of famous figures that he
aspires to be like you know I detect a hint of
narcissism there but maybe not I mean you got
to aim high but I can also see how this might be a
person who isn't completely aware of you know the
use of his own power and status and whatnot um and
I don't know I mean here we can go into some more
of the facts here testimonials and allegations
uh during the first four days of trial Jabari
testified uh testified that Majors injured her
while attempting to snatch his phone after seeing
a text message allegedly perhaps from some other
woman um you know and the charges here directly
relate to this alleged incident in the car so I
mean there's been a lot of other stuff brought to
light and I know that there's debate about uh what
kind of character-based evidence is admissible
and or you know should be taken seriously in a
case like this um on the defense and prosecution
strategy side um you know the defense argued that
Majors was preventing Jabari from running into
traffic while the prosecution approached the
case as you know your more straight domestic
violence situation uh the defense question jaar's
credibility suggested she was seeking Revenge
which you know is well documented especially on
message Bo boards and whatnot um and uh John boa
Tori got brought into the convo and people started
talking about recasting Kang yeah I've seen youra
I've seen johon boa I was saying y'd be great but
I think Wonder man's still happening oh I mean he
can be both you know I mean what if the character
is a variant of K yeah uh and and I mean you know
it's uh I mean yeah and people are saying there's
there's a a literally video of him hurting her at
some point which I have I've seen the video
of him running away from you know down the
down many blocks create through training at work
which I mean yeah that that whole thing seemed
like sort of we're in the midst of some kind of
heated altercation and and I just want to get
out of this but again that's that's the thing we
don't know details of right if you've got someone
running away from something it could be like I
just messed up and I realize it I'm running away
or it could be she's going to do something to me I
need to run away we weren't there and that's what
I think is so messy about releasing that footage
and of course it's TMZ and people like that that
do it because they want this conversation yeah
and uh I mean you know from the the prosecution
side jabari's attorney Ross Kramer has expressed
satisfaction with the verdict and highlighted
jabari's courage uh the statement hoped uh the
verdict would Inspire other victims of assault
to come forward and I mean this is one of the
trickiest things to parse in terms of the law
you know is is these kinds of situations because
so much does come down to he said she said sit
situations that are only going to be described
and nobody has direct account for other than the
people involved um so I guess on that note I would
encourage y'all in the chat to at least you know
be conscientious with your level of commitment to
whatever side of this that you have committed to
because I just I think it's probably fool hearty
to assume that just any one of us Rando normal
people knows intimately what has been going on
and uh absolutely Amanda Jay Washington for Kang
all day um so yeah uh trial observations Majors uh
who attended every day of the two-e trial did not
testify um and remained you know mostly stoic
emotionless except for during the uh closing
arguments closing statements um and the defense
argued that you know Jabari was the aggressor and
suggested that she injured herself after Revenge
partying there those videos out of her after the
alleged incident you know in in a bar of some
kind um evidence included surveillance footage and
photos um you know the prosecution's evidence uh
introduced texts and recordings between the two of
them alleging a pattern of abuse uh the evidence
was intended to show major character and potential
for committing the alleged crimes and and I mean
that's the thing about this case for me and yes
I believe the writer strike and the actor strike
are both over uh they have voted right likei we
are up until two and a half years from now we're
we're we're working so everyone's back to work
everyone's good um and this is the longest like I
think into of the holidays we've worked because of
it I think we're going come back quicker like
usually La shuts down for like two weeks yeah
yeah uh and so yeah I mean that's that's a thing
for me this this this last bit that we just read
you know the the evidence that they introduced you
know intended to show a potential for you know the
capability of committing these uh acts and whatnot
and I mean that's that's the thing I don't know
exactly none of us do what happened that day but
it does seem like the potential for this to be a
toxic relationship was there and uh and certain
of those behaviors while maybe not all illegal
certainly don't ring very well um so I don't know
that that has been a lot of my inspiration to kind
of keep uh an arms length from any solid I don't
know from choosing a side too heavily yeah yeah
yeah um because again it's it's like there's a lot
of and and from what I've heard about the actual
proceedings uh beyond the information that we know
you know there's certainly uh strange and hinky
details regarding Jabari story there are strange
and hinky details uh regarding major story um and
yeah the I got to feel like some tangible thing
exists in the middle of that even if it's not
exactly what we're seeing or hearing at the moment
there where there's I hesitate to say but where
there's smoke there could be fire um and in the
Manhattan da statement uh the district attorney
Al Alvin Bragg emphasized the trials focus on
Survivor centered Justice and the pattern of
abuse and coercion identified in Major's case
and I mean that's something again looking at
some of those text messages uh about like oh you
know don't worry I'm not going to tell people uh
you know about what really happened or whatever
or you know oh I I'm going to downplay whatever
this you know injury was and whatnot like those
those things certainly read like codependency and
not wanting to anger somebody that you might be
a bit afraid of um and I mean hey I mean and and
people were saying like you know I mean this isn't
to say I mean again I brought up Johnny Depp and
Amber herd partly because um you know this this
guy says she was clearly grabbing him and she even
took his phone and hit him with it and wouldn't
let him leave I don't know and that's the thing
is I I brought up Johnny Depp and Amber herd
partly because that situation certainly seemed
to me given everything like even if you have your
opinions about who is more of the innocent or the
aggressor in that situation it seems like abuses
happened back and forth either way so uh you know
you can be in a situation where yeah maybe she
was attacking him that particular day but it also
seems like there's more to it than just Jonathan
major has a severely abusive girlfriend you know
what I mean uh no I'm not I'm not trying to victim
blame at all I'm just trying to say that we are
not there for all the details and certainly I am
the kind of person if you want like a uh you know
transparency I am the kind of person who yeah is
more inclined to side with a Survivor uh you know
somebody in jabari's position certainly however
again you look at the am again like looking at
the Amber herd trial that's somebody who at
first I might have been inclined to be like
well I'm I until her account is proven otherwise
I I'm kind of suspect of the other side but also
that went to show us that two people and and
what the thing is life isn't cut and dry two
people can have abuses toward each other and you
and I are both like Johnny Depp fans like we both
I mean like Hunter Thompson era Johnny Depp is
is like so formative to my movie going experience
and Hunter's absolutely a literary hero of mine
but I think it's important to look past the her
on screen and look at the evidence as best you
can and again that's what's hard about this is
asking 70% of the chat what they think is uh they
make decisions not based off any actual evidence
because we don't have enough EV evidence you have
to go with what you do have um which wasn't much
obviously you know it does look like there was
violence and that is what you have to look at
not at how you perceive the person and if she
said uh that he never attacked her before this
incident in court then that's good to know I mean
being attacked at any point is probably not good
um but yeah I don't know I mean clearly we're not
all going to agree in this chat but uh you know
I appreciate y'all weighing in at the very least
and we do have a couple of super chats let's jump
over there real quick and uh see what y'all have
to say in there um isn't this just the most fun
way to start the week it wasn't gre's anniversary
and he didn't ask me d there's no way this is like
the DMV this is just the wor I know why dude like
I love you I love you Coy and I love I love the
DMV 10 to 12% of people here I love the DMV well
let's jump into uh uh the direct thoughts of y'all
the peeps and let's enlarge this window so it's
the right size there we go all righty all righty
all right thank you guys again for showing up and
for yeah and for contributing and just you know
for uh airing out your thoughts and bearing with
us as we talk about this awkward difficult weird
situation that none of us civilians are actually
qualified to be commenting on um but yeah uh let's
see somebody asked why do you guys think this
happens at the height of someone's career well I I
mean that's in a lot of General situations I would
just say that for some people it's really hard to
watch some somebody who may have caused you this
distress and pain rise to the top and be hoisted
onto a platform and be celebrated and adored by
so many people um you know I don't know there's
so much made about the time in which things get
reported and uh it's one of the most unique and
horrific kinds of experiences you can report
to anybody and share with people so to be uh
a as transparent as possible I think on one side
it's someone hoping that the reach um will get
actual awareness brought to something if that's
the case whether that's them being duplicitous
or them being like I need to get out of this so I
need to make it public because something horrible
happened either one of those things or it's
because uh there's a lot of pressure when you're
doing well like there's a lot of pressure when
you're doing 18 hour days and you're having to
do all of this press and you're running around and
maybe that's when you snap so either it's because
of someone thinking this is the best time to get
Awareness on something or it's something to deal
with someone's mental state uh because of pressure
it it kind of makes sense to happen at the height
of something for a lot of reasons uh pressure
makes diamonds but also makes explosions um so
it makes sense especially if you're yeah I mean
if you are living some kind of life in which you
are trying to conceal and or Crush down or maybe
you're not even fully aware of your behavior yeah
like when you're at the Pinnacle and you have all
these opportunities like that's a stressful life
that's a lot going on like you said but also
people get sloppy people slip up all sorts of
things can happen and I mean the more you have
to lose I got to imagine uh you know the more
tense and and sort of I don't know I think that
can do things to your mindset you know when you
have so many things to manage and you've got
a status and you have you know risen to such a
place you know I think people are often fearful of
losing that obviously um but yeah uh there's a lot
of uh interesting chatter going on in the chat but
let's see what the supers have to say Stefan thank
you for joining us thank you for uh sharing your
thoughts on the funnest day of the year hey guys
I listen to the live stream playbacks on my night
shifts oh that's awesome uh thank you John Coy and
Greg for everything you do love you all and Happy
Holidays love you and uh that's amazing yeah I
mean you know we got our podcast that we listen to
on late nights and if we can do that for any and
all any of you guys I mean that's uh it makes
me happy hopefully they're more fun than this
one normally and I appreciate that I we can get
you through your shifts you're here for this one
yeah don't worry next next shift will be much
nicer uh Isaiah Maas I hope Marvel Studios and
thank you for contributing especially again this
isn't the most like upbeat uh you know reason to
jump in the chat but uh a very much uh appreciate
uh you chiming in I hope Marvel Studios simply has
Jonathan major State a public apology and have
him remain his Kang since he is found guilty
of two unintentional charges um and I mean I'm
very curious to see what becomes of this if he
does do jail time because yeah I mean at least
again as of the verdict they convicted him only
of the you know non premeditated versions of
this I mean which is its own kind of trouble
you know arguably ideala everybody should have
enough self-control uh you know to try and you
know not find yourself in a situation like this um
but you know everybody's different I don't foresee
this happening quite honestly because again the
details of the case are so heavily debated and
this is just going to follow him for the time
being anyway and the trouble is that his star
I think Rose in a way that when he was announced
um you know as Kang I feel like that's people had
seen Lovecraft country people had been buzzing
about this guy but when he became Kang I have
to to think that that's when most of the the
broad swath of the populace kind of found out
who this guy is and you know having him uh yeah
like having uh this person tied so specifically
to this brand this universe this character I
feel like it would be hard to go about it this
way doing you know some kind of apology and
then you know letting him continue on I don't
know if this necessarily means that his acting
career is over after whatever time gets served
or after whatever I think he'll serve time because
of the the charges that actually were guilty I I
honestly think maybe probation personally uh
I don't know I'm not a lawyer but I I don't
I don't I mean obviously Marvel's already fired
him but he hadn't at this point of this is like
our second Super Chat so this was not through
yet but um he doesn't work for Marvel anymore
that said with these charges I I don't think
uh personally I don't think it' be jail time
we'll see yeah yeah I would be I guess somewhat
surprised uh but yeah I feel like it's probably
going to be kind of starting from scratch and
and who knows what kind of Public Image rehab
he's going to have to do because too with Marvel
and everything I mean he has you know certainly
been the subject of just more and more and more
of those kinds of you fun interviews and like oh
here's 10 Things I can't live with that you know
like his his uh star has risen but also just his
you know status as a public Personality yeah his
own his own personality and and I I it's a it's
always hard again when someone that you respect
in both the public Persona and character Persona
like I really enjoyed Jonathan Major's interviews
I really enjoyed his worldview his perspective all
those things and that definitely colored my
experience of the trials but as someone who
has the responsibility of knowing that people
are listening to my opinion whether they're
immediately judging it or not I'm aware that my
experience of Jonathan major made me want this
to be innoc and that's why it's so hard because
you come with all of your preconceived notions of
what this person is that you have to hope the
judge and jury are capable of separating that
how much exposure they have to him like not most
people we're on a movie chat right now if you're
in here you are on a movie chat most people the
average person especially probably in a jury has
not watched hours of someone's interviews um so
it's really hard when you do care about this actor
if you care about their talent you care about
their work to have any sort of removal of that
when judging a a legal situation so um it is a
mess uh and I don't think the the charges will
turn to jail time but I do think this is obviously
a giant shift in public perception that Marvel is
dancing now yeah and everybody in the chat has
also been asking about what about Ezra Miller
which is always a fair point um yeah I mean Ezra
Miller certainly should have been dealt with in a
different way than they were were uh not I don't
know it's weird because it's like Ezra Miller has
way more alleged you know crimes under their belt
and N none of yeah I don't know there's no real
real good reason why you know Ezra Miller should
remain and you know Majors should not or whatever
you know but Ezra's not still flash I think that I
don't know if people are assuming that he is like
that's not a yeah I I I think that I don't know
um it it is both two really messy public trials
but other than that I don't know um where things
landed with the Ezra Miller trial like I don't
know where they are with all of that right now
so it's not really I don't know I I don't have
enough data gotcha yeah yeah and no more no
more flash for Ezra and and two I I do think
it's that thing of like all these I think there is
a hypocrisy I guess in the court of public opinion
and the way it interacts with business because
because if you look at the rrap sheet of alleged
crimes from Ezra Miller uh some of them border on
this territory but there's nothing as cut and dry
as like oh you know you're you're this kind of
abuser I feel like it would have been much more
Swift in that sense if that had been the case um
again trying to trying to dance around some of
these more sensitive issues for because YouTube
is is sensitive um but yeah MC uh no light um
MC no light uh I'm sorry but this is pure [__]
uh appreciate your opinion appreciate you jumping
in uh I mean you know I won't say that there's
nothing can be debated about this but uh you
know I don't know I don't know if I would say
[__] but but you know to each their own I
suppose coiler hair thank you for chiming in on
the chat uh the text telling her don't go to the
hospital uh due to the fact that he can't come to
uh what she says sealed his fate uh I mean if I'm
reading this this correctly uh I mean sure that's
not really a good look if you're you know that's
Max of trying to control the situation yourself
and that sort of leads you to think that oh maybe
there is some kind of yeah guilt at hand um
I I do think the um the making it seem like a
pattern not a single incident was what made this
a different trial I I think the incident in the
car is obviously what this trial was about but the
text from months earlier um basically saying you
know don't don't go to the hospital they'll ask
too many questions shows some level of repeat um
problem so it it's it's not uh I I again everyone
on both sides of this seems like it's been a real
mess I don't don't know I wasn't there same I was
there just kidding I know all this stuff Maser
is if they fire thank you by the way uh if they
fire Jonathan Majors then surely they will just
keep Kang and have a variant that doesn't look
like Majors I'm very curious I don't know the
exact details of the contract I have heard it said
once that he had some kind of stipulation in there
that only he could play King and I've had I've
been curious about that this whole time because
there obviously have been certain characters
in the MCU in the Multiverse that we have seen
portrayed by multiple actors Loki certainly being
one of them um again I don't know if some kind of
intervening legal circumstance like this kind of
uh renders that null and void because you know
I guess I would imagine and I not a contract law
expert but I would imagine that you know part of
any contract rides on you being in good standing
with the law um but yeah you know I don't know I
I I mean certainly that seems like the easiest
thing to do and and like the Multiverse would
give you an easy out in that sense but I don't
know if it even makes sense um to be honest the
way the way they're navigating the MCU now is lots
of damage control like if you look at what they're
doing with Captain America 4 adding six months of
reshoots which is effectively a new movie if you
look at what they're doing with allowing Deadpool
to be the only movie next year to give people like
you know time to recalibrate and and downtime for
fans to me it it looks like phase six is damage
control and the second half of phase five is is
buttoning up as much as you can um it doesn't to
me make sense to keep the character of Kang um the
way Loki ended allows for that to be the end of
Kang in a way um I do think it's a bummer for Doom
as a character to not have um the same impactful
opening of taking over the the big bad because I
don't think that would make sense it also doesn't
really make sense to have the impacts work if you
have a recast Kang be taken out by Doom because
then you're just like we just met that guy like
you're whether or not you know it's Kang you're
still going to perceive an actor as playing him
as a new actor playing him so you will have just
met him um I also don't think that they handled
you know Kang that well in Antman so we've had
really good Kang in the periphery uh not everyone
watches Loki everyone that watches the MCU movies
don't watch the show so the one MCU movie we've
had of Kang wasn't the best debut as is like his
his scenes were great but the movie wasn't in
my opinion so I don't know if Kang does go on I
think that might be why Destin Daniel keton left I
think that you know he had a plan with as planned
MCU and when that changed he was like all right
let's Avengers 5 you guys do your thing um I'mma
make Shang chiu sooner now yay uh I I honestly
think that you find a new way to introduce Doom
um you lean on the impact of the character and
uh I I don't know if i' I'd touch Kang again yeah
because the trouble is yeah major made Kang like
that's the trouble is like major is so charismatic
and so talented that's what made Kang I don't
know if the character yeah that's a very good
point CU because yeah people are so tied to his
name and yeah it it catapulted him into such yeah
stardom certainly past all the buzz that already
existed yeah I'm I'm not sure I don't think uh
sorry I'm also being distracted by scrolling
through stuff um but yeah uh I think that's a
a really solid Point basically that uh yeah he's
he's so associated with the character now that I
don't think people would be able to not talk about
it if Kang is around at least for a long time if
they bring in a new Iron Man that gets taken out
in one movie you're not going to suddenly go like
oh I love Iron Man You're Gonna Go like where's
Downey also what happened oh that fake Iron Man's
gone it'll just feel like a it'll feel desperate
I think yeah we're going to run through the rest
of these super chats but we're probably going
to wrap things up in about 15 20 minutes people
unless uh you know unless anything crazy happens
but uh gala ghost Andre good to see you bud thank
you for joining in the chat hey guys unfortunate
news on many ends but great seeing you both here
love the positive energy you guys bring wish you a
happy holidays and cheers thank you bud appreciate
you being here and yeah I wish it was on a better
circumstance a nicer occasion but it's always a
nice occasion to see your face so appreciate that
Joy being town man I'm jealous extreme Viper 99
thank you for chiming in hey Koy John and Greg
just want to say you guys inspire me so much
real rejects have got me through a hard year love
you all thanks for the laughs Lads absolutely man
that means a lot thank you yeah it's my favorite
content helps me through tough times and times
always seem to be tricky so uh so yeah that means
a lot Nate Saunders kind of disappointed thought
he was a great actor absolutely the the whole
thing is disappointing I'm sad the whole thing
makes me sad I don't know like it's it's it's sad
that any of this had to be the case whatever the
the truth of the matter is beyond what we know
yeah it's I don't I don't understand anybody
who's like getting Glee out of this situation but
uh extreme Viper 99 thank you for chiming back
in uh also have an amazing Christmas guys and New
Year same to you same to all of you can't believe
that we are already what day is it today it's the
18th we got like it's a week till Christmas man
week from today what do you guys for Christmas
leave us what you want for Christmas in the chat
King Tut if this has taught us anything when
you are famous thank you for contributing by
the way stay away from any uh stay away from them
crazy white girls I know Co feel what I'm saying
I don't know about John I mean I I I I love all
kinds of people man so but I'll be sure to stay
away from white girls from now on although I don't
know what ethnicity is that name Jabari like you
know let's let's let's dig deeper you know maybe
I don't I don't know I uh white people of all of
all stripes are are crazy in their in their way
people are messy and uh I'm a crazy white girl I
that's true I've seen it that's that's real yeah
you know it's how we do over here Louise Feliciano
uh what if thank you by the way what if season
2 is hinting at Thanos coming back could it be
possible that Thanos returns not just what if
but also the Avengers Disneyland ride has been
hinting at Thanos uh I do think we get Thanos
in uh in secret Wars in some way um and maybe
that's a way to show the power of Doom right maybe
instead of Doom taking out um Kang it takes out
Thanos easily maybe there's some way to leverage
our you know emotional connection to how great
Thanos was for you know two acts in the second and
third Act growing into 3x um as a way to make that
impact so that could be um absolutely a way to do
it but I do think we get Thanos at least a little
bit in one of the secret Wars absolute vodka MC
Pringle thank you for being here once you pop the
fun does not stop especially with you hey dudes
CAD uh glad I could finally make it to a stream
wish it was under better circumstances you and us
both all three yep do you guys think recasting or
replac is more likely thanks for all that y'all
do love from Jersey love to Jersey say what's up
to Miss Marvel uh yeah I mean we've we've trotten
this territory over the stream a fair amount um it
seems like just pivoting to a different character
is the most likely scenario I I just think it's
cleaner and I think uh as I said a few minutes
ago but I think that the amount of re retroactive
tweaks is already pretty high so I I don't think
they'd want to you know dig that hole any deeper
with this phase five going into F six I think
they're trying to streamline and clean up things
yeah absolutely they've got so many things to
clean up and they have so many characters we've
only seen once one nerdy perspective thank you so
much for being here and sharing your perspective
I thoroughly enjoy it when koi says what we all
want to um thanks I appreciate that uh voice of
the people I just have a lot of a lot of opinions
and uh and you know you guys help those come out
for better or worse and all the in between Cory
M thank you for being here thank you for chiming
in very glad the victim got Justice she deserved
hoping the best for her absolutely Majors needs to
seek help and hopefully become a better person
also true I mean if again I'm not going to the
continual disclaimer we don't know these people
but I mean I guess the hope is always that through
this difficult and highly debatable scenario you
know hopefully these people at least have some
cause to look Inward and and yeah I yeah I hope
grow from the experience I hope both parties uh
find whatever next phase of their life to be
better than this one because these people have
been in court for months and obviously dealt with
a really toxic relationship before the trial so I
hope both of them uh find their next chapter of
life so much happier than this one absolutely
and you know I mean it's about grow and and uh
uh what's the word you know I mean these kinds
of things yes punishments are doled out but you
know you also hope that Rehabilitation or growth
is also part of the process not just like ah
damn I'm bummed that I got punished you know
uh MC no light those 2022 messages are heavily
redacted no context at all given not denying
he was manipulative and narcissistic but using
those messages when they don't even pertain to
this case is dangerous uh and that's a a situation
in which like I'm I'm looking forward to the legal
eagle video on this uh or I learned who that was
recently sure that was a good journey for me GRE
tell me all about the s s snipers that's right
oh sniper and the legal yeah and the leg legal
of all that oh boy attorneys at law yeah and and
I mean I don't know I get what you're saying and
I know a lot of people have brought this up and
I know that for this particular case they were
using a fair amount of character-based evidence
to you know support the idea of whether or not
this person would be capable of these actions uh
I don't really know enough to comment on the rules
of that alls I know is it certainly does uh paint
a certain character light um and I could see how
that would be relevant to a situation like this
I can see how you might take issue with that as
well um so I yeah I don't really have a solid
retort here um you know Fair Point uh Brandon
Jed John and Coy can be the new Kang variance
thank you for your vote of confidence I think
we would do a great job I think we're what the
people want you know replace this guy with two
white guys two of them and they're like C like
we like two Hales yeah you can you can sit on my
shoulders and we'll wear a trench coat the only
way will be as big as Majors big Absolut I mean
you know you're getting there you're getting
there true working on Michelle thank you for
being here and uh and yeah appreciate hey we're
doing our best you know I'm sure there are more
reputable news sites you know for keeping in the
loop with but yeah I appreciate you being here and
I hope that we're able to at least yeah I don't
know bring some relevant perspective on this to
your day uh straw wild appreciate you very much
for being here I appreciate the community you've
cultivated thank you I do too I feel like I mean
you know especially in a live stream you get every
kind of opinion but generally I often feel like we
have a very positive and and a very upbeat comment
section and a and just community in general I like
more of reject Nation than I don't absolute vodka
the good guy uh the da needs to in uh invest to
be inv investigated there's been too many cases
of this nature and the others are suing for what
they've done in the past that's good to know uh
I mean I'm sure that anybody who is delivered a
verdict is going to you know try and uh appeal or
you know if they don't feel like they have been
served justce you know try and get some kind of
alternate ruling or whatever um but if that's
the case I mean I would have to look into this
particular district attorney I don't know much
about them but that's alarming if true Alex Leif
appreciate you being here famous man breaks up
with woman woman then levels assault accusations
against man I wonder when I've heard this story
before did they break up and then she leveled the
accusations that wasn't my understanding of this
um but I mean I don't know if you're if you want
to view these things as Petty I guess that's going
to be your choice and uh and I probably will not
dissuade you from it I personally don't see these
kinds of uh situations as you know the kind you
would want to get into flippantly uh but I'm glad
you understand Nuance I think it's important you
look at everything as black and white because
that's how the world is and that's a Healthy
Outlook and I'm sure things will go well for you
all I'm gonna go to the next one yeah absolutely
I was just gonna help I was going to give you a
second there Aiden wagland his I am a great man
rant is so arrogant and shows how out of touch he
is also love the vids and Coy I unabashedly love
your Twitter takes and how you tell people off
when they're bitter about it uh yeah the the great
man rant is is an interesting one and and I mean
cly didn't bother me nearly as much as it bothered
a lot of people like when you actually listen
to it as opposed to reading the transcription
of it he was I mean obviously an actor thinking of
himself as Martin Luther King is a bold statement
but the the statement itself was about him saying
he is put in the Limelight he is someone that is
leading and he is someone that is under a lot of
pressure and as a great man he needs a great woman
and in transcription again aggressively naive
but anyone in the public eye anyone under a lot
of pressure wants someone supporting them again I
don't think that calling someone uh Martin Luther
King as like a peer is a logical thing to do but
I do understand saying like hey I am under a lot
of pressure I need someone behind me uh I just do
think that it's a very manipulative tactic on both
parties I'm under a lot of pressure I striving for
greatness yeah I'm representing people and I and
I'm trying to do my best again I don't know what
led up to that conversation what happened after
that conversation all I'm saying is that uh the
actual rant itself uh bothered me a bit less but
I'm also arrogance as [__] so I get it um and
thank you uh I I'm trying to for my own mental
health use Twitter less but I appreciate that and
there will be times I'm at 30k when I want to get
to 40K I'll go on TI raids again and uh for now
though I'm gonna try to find peace which is not
happening today absolutely uh yeah I would have to
I I need to hear the actual uh uh audio I guess I
yeah it changes a lot and I and and too even on
the transcri yeah it's it's in the amalgamation
that it becomes Telltale to me because yeah
it's like I get it and and I understand that
a lot of people in this position have to have a
high opinion of themselves and enough that they
will you know push and see their you know uh
goals through and all that stuff and build the
kind of life that you know he's trying to build
so yeah like in isolation I don't begrudge that
right um so much Jeff Carroll got a few from you
let's see how far we are okay we're almost to the
end here so I'm going to close off the super
chats and uh we're going to read the the final
few here and and then we will let y'all get
on about your day um let's see real quick cuz
we gotta blow everything up yeah here we go here
we go but yeah thank you guys for being here and
for the most part being you know respectful
and uh and constructive with your thoughts
and feelings uh we do appreciate y'all being here
and for you know again if we didn't have uh y'all
to to to to chat to and to bounce all this stuff
off of you know we wouldn't have a stream at all
so appreciate y'all uh for keeping us on track
and uh okay let's get back to it let's read the
the last of the supers here we do have a a fair
amount more than I expected today which is nice
which is lovely appreciate y'all uh again for just
uh being so supportive uh you know again despite
how kind of icky all of this has been um let's
see okay so we were on Jeff Carol one of3 MCU is
a tough situation that Kang is so important and
so much groundwork has been laid that it doesn't
seem smart to abandon the character but they also
might feel it safer to have a clean slate either
to avoid controversy not confuse casual fans or
move in a different direction hope for the best
for the MCU if recast my pick is Lei Stanfield
all love unrelated uh but Percy Jackson in two
days can't wait I've been hearing a lot of great
things about the Percy Jackson TV Disney streaming
series whatever that is and uh and yeah I think
you know you're you're absolutely correct this
is going to be a tough either way this is going
to be tough for Marvel pivoting and adjusting to
this and uh and yeah it seems like they have
put down a lot of track under the Kang train
but uh yeah I mean certainly to avoid controversy
I got to believe they're going to have to go in a
different direction because uh I don't I think
it'll be way way too distracting I personally
agree I also think that the track they put under
him is a bit Rocky uh like yeah there's track but
they also have that post credit scene that shows
all of the majors as Kang so it's hard to do if
you're considering and all people talk about postc
credit scenes they don't actually talk about the
movie so if the one of the most important moments
being a post credit scene is the two minutes where
all of them are Majors how do you have that and
then also the messus of the storyline and the
way lowy end it allows for it to end so I think
I think it's a good move to to end the Kang Arc
um but I also think um I don't know uh what was
the last thing sorry um uh oh Leith uh Leith is
my brother voodoo man I think's energy is is he's
got this mysticism to him like there's this this
undercurrent of like he's got this knowledge
that like he knows something and after Haunted
Mansion especially I feel like he'd be such a good
brother Voodoo uh so he that's where he is for me
that's sounds beautiful thank you Jeff Carrol
for chiming in I'll take any Lei appearance in
the MCU or otherwise wise the orange pill nurse
thank you for chiming in the same media Outlets
that villainized him and Miss rep uh resented the
facts from the case variety we'll do an article
on this on his comeback years from now watch you
guys know my thoughts on variety yeah I and that's
only because they did used to be a trusted Source
like I really like variety um seven years ago and
earlier there their clickbait like anybody else
know I mean if you work on the internet you got
to appeal to the worst of society that's fair
that's why we're here on a Monday that's what
we do extreme Viper 999 Kang next time baby and uh
he's going to be in armor Wars now they're going
to recast RO with Jonathan Maj uh Nate Feliciano
thank you Viper as well uh Hey Coy and John Nate
Feliciano thank you for being here love y'all and
all you do how would you guys feel as John boa as
Kang I mean I love John boa I will take any John
boa in the MCU that I can get I think in the chat
people have said said that he has been shutting
that down on social media but uh I mean if I was
treated like that by Disney I weren't for Disney
again yeah like he literally had a character and
built a Arc and I mean I was shocked that Oscar
Isaac came back he would never come back in Star
Wars I don't think I mean he even said as much
they uh Perry asked him if he'd ever come back
in the Disney Plus show and he was like nope
so I think he came back for moonnight because
the story worked and he got to have a little bit
more control but um if I was John boa I wouldn't
I wouldn't work for Disney again nope NOP NP gala
ghost thank you for chiming back in on dress I
will say it here first all the kangs introduced so
far are Scrolls posing his variant of Kang wink I
think that would be a very fun tons and tons of
like that we they re-shoot the post credit scene
and then like they use the frame they use but then
just like they all turn into Scrolls yeah and then
Nick Fury walks out and he's like see I delivered
on my promise I found you on you a place to live
and now you just got to show up dressed as this
guy sometimes Manuel Rodriguez the thank you for
chiming in the Jonathan situ uh major situation is
very unfortunate and messed up Marvel just have to
break everything down and rebuild at this point
uh I don't know they're already in a position
where they need to kind of do maintenance while
driving the car so I mean there's other stuff I
think like the thing is if they were in a great
place storytelling wise I would be more concerned
but thus far I mean other than the portend
that Jonathan major as Kang is going to be a
significant part of the next you know two phases
these you know Multiverse Saga phases uh yeah I
mean I feel like they have it is an unfortunate
situation and uh I feel like they're already
rebuilding themselves anyway so while while it's
messy I would just yeah yeah and they've been
sitting on this for months watching this they've
had other problems to deal with um shevi D thank
you for being here for chiming in Marvel really
screwed thems elv with the qu media post credit
scene and having Kang play every single variant
also I love watching you guys yeah yeah and I mean
I'm sure anybody who's not uh you know as plugged
in but who's stuck around for that post credit
scene will be certainly maybe taking aack when
they never see this character again but uh yeah
we'll see uh hey Dan v900 thanks for chiming in
appreciate seeing you as well oh and somebody sent
their first Supra thank you so yeah there's been
a few of those KY Clemens is a really is really
good in dope and great in hearts beat loud in
Monarch it's the writing and directing where she's
charismatic and can sing she's just a bland hacker
and it stinks this is a random out of nowhere Dan
v900 out of nowhere but thanks for keeping up
with uh I don't know if you've been keeping up
with our Monarch reactions uh it certainly has
felt as though kiry Clemens is doing everything
she can to carry the script that they have given
her character those three leads on that show man
like I don't I don't really blame the actors at
all just like the way they written it's so Ted
rough it's tedious man it's weird like there's
a lot of cool stuff about it's a people really
love the show okay uh there's fun stuff about it
I like watching it but I do think that it's one of
those shows you watch where you're sort of taken
back by how much people are like this is great cuz
you're like cuz you're like these I and I and
and in the reviews for the episodes we've bent
over backwards to to basically address that like
yeah people aren't coming to any Godzilla thing
or they typically aren't for you know character
drama but Godzilla minus one they can but in the
age of Godzilla minus one they can and also just
yeah looking at this I'm like oh there's so many
other storylines where like the tone and and
everything comes together in a way that works
and uh and this this beat with kiry like kiry
Clemens of the three present day timeline leads
is I think the best performer like she's always
doing great work but like when the it's always a
matter of when the script backs her up and only on
like episode seven have I felt that way so far and
kiry is exceptional in dope and hearts Beed loud
kir is fantastic I got a lot love her so yeah uh
thank you for that uh just a little interstitial
and all five seconds of The Flash that she was in
yeah C ghost I want a Fight Club reaction for
Christmas you I don't know man you never know
it might happen you just keep your eyes peeled but
it might be just me lurking in the corner watching
him watch it because I've seen it so many times
and just being like hey did you catch that after
this we're gonna go fight each other out back
what do you know by yourself you never been in
a fight Bucky bar I mean that's that's a fair qu
see that's one of those fascinating movies where
I'm like I get how this is part of the you know
easy to misinterpret starter pack easy to like
if you're idolizing this you maybe got the wrong
message starter pack but at the same time it's
because there are certain details and philosophies
where you are like well but that in isolation or
that as a jumping off point is fair it's almost
like archb nuanced it you know much like life I
don't think so Co we should black and like very
much think this is one or the other thing nothing
in the middle nope never never uh Nuance smash
the like button says Bucky Barnes ATL give it up
for Bucky Barnes always holding it down moderating
the chat uh smash the like button like koi smashes
the weights look at that hugging those biceps
get after it you lovelies I'm very excited for
a little time off for gym just just consum off
to go to the gym go to the gym just just gains
and can't wait I'm just gonna eat and go to the
gym I'm just like it's gonna be I think we I only
have like a week uh I have like six days we're
not scheduled and it's usually like two weeks but
those six days two a days absolutely very excited
about love it love that love you're going to be
just like uh you're just going to be a little tiny
head on just a big old pile of muscles come back
as a cumulus cloud in just want to reemerge I love
that cumulus koi Jason felle happy holidays to you
and your to you to and your family happy holidays
to you and yours as well appreciate you chiming
in thank you for the support happy uh it is the
holiday season is as d as the subject matter of
this stream is it is the holidays and it's nice
to have you all here Maro Schmidt wiie crazy thank
you for uh chiming in crazy to think that they had
major terminated termination papers on standby oh
oh you bet I mean they've had so many months to
draft those up you know they just had somebody
on verdict Day sitting with a pen and the shredder
you know which way are we going yeah so dark uh do
not envy anyone in this situation no Marley Morgan
thank you for jumping in I kind of wanted iron lad
well you never know this could still happen you
know maybe they'll do like a like a little man
thing where they CGI Robert Downey Jr's head onto
a tiny body iron land turns out to be king but in
this version he can't I'm just letting you know
that well Dow's not coming back either so we're
not getting either iron you never know latty you
never know I don't care how many times Kevin feige
in the game like we're not going to mess up the
Iron Man Arc I'm like well what do you do now uh
don't don't do it but uh hey you know who knows
maybe that'll be the way to introduce Kang later
down the line a bunch bunch later 19 phase 19 iron
lad show up different face or maybe Jonathan major
is completely changed by then and he's back who
knows pav thank you for being here greetings from
Poland love you guys absolutely oh my goodness
thank you for tuning in what time is it in Poland
it's got to be at least in the evening or or
middle of the day it's got the for us yeah so it's
got to be the evening for you shii D thank you
for joining in uh Coy can read our minds love from
South Africa damn Poland and South Africa in the
chat is that the Rand is that a is that those I so
I went to South Africa for for a few weeks uh back
in the day and I still have some I think they're
called Rand the South African currency uh I stayed
in uh Cape Town and then went out into the desert
about five hours out of Cape Town for Africa burn
had myself a lovely time at Africa burn uh but the
whiskey and the meat pies and the vaccinos uh
the Vino is like a it's like a chocolate coffee
smoothie uh is my like favorite food like facino
at in Cape Town much love to South AF Boogie also
uh it's Marcus Nicholas CES King Nicholas King uh
so but yeah Shi thank you for yeah for chiming in
uh that's so cool God South Africa Poland that's
awesome uh Dylan Walker thank you for joining CH
joining joining and chiming are the two words
I tried to say at the same time will this be
another road situation in terms of seamless
transition Nigeria Australia just giv giv some
love to interrupt but that's exciting absolutely
not bad oh so I that's one of my favorite things
is just seeing the world the global map of of
viewership and and the reject nation is Broad
you know love feels good Dylan Walker will this
be another Roadie situation in terms of seamless
transition of characters this one man was entire
Citadel how can we disconnect yeah that's kind of
what I'm thinking Dylan it's not quite the same I
mean that there's that one great line of dialogue
from uh from Don chenel saying like I'm here it's
me get over it like just deal with it uh I think
he says and and I thought that was such a genius
way to handle a recasting I don't know if they
can do that with a citadel of one man playing a
character across uh time in universes it's also
conquered time and I feel like they were trying
to make that him fighting himself and the power
of major acting really made that uh you know a
man versus Man story I honestly don't see how
K could be someone else yeah unfortunately tiari
ngoi I hope I uh I probably butchered your name
there I'm sorry but thank you for being here Jada
pink at his k let's be positive he'll recover oh
golly you know in in in in an alternate universe
where they're about to release Scary Movie 6 I'm
sure that J is K she literally shows up as Kang
and Scary Movie 6 and the Press tour would just
be hearing about Tupac I would just be like all
right we get it you uh want to tell us how close
you were to Tupac and I believe some of this she's
still close to him he's still alive she it's true
he's out in Vegas Elvis is not de went home Ving
MC no light thank you for once again Shing in very
generous today apologies if I came off as Brash
being an AA man in America this just hit me a
bit emotional thank you guys and hope you both
have a great holiday hey hey uh afrian America
sure yeah absolutely well and and and I mean too
there is that like and and I know that certainly
African-American men are often subject to these
situations where you're portrayed as violent or
you know something along on those lines and I
mean I guess I can't pretend that there's not
any of that involved in this situation I I guess
I wouldn't be of the mind to just attribute all
of this to that right now but absolutely like
I don't I don't take issue with people being
emotional over this because it is a bummer it is
a messy situation it does seem kind of it seems
at least a bit tricky to feel like you have a
cut and dry answer and so at the very least uh
I mean yeah aside from the people being blatantly
disrespectful yeah like I can't blame you or take
away from you being emotional about this and and
any kind of heated feelings that might come from
that because it is I don't know these things also
Force us to look around at systems in society look
at ourselves look at you know people we know you
know they're very human situations and it does
suck that this uh this character that was so well
played by Jonathan majers is going to be either
dropped or retooled in either way way that's a
mess and and I I I can't imagine you know the
the the people that are in the chat going like
well yeah when you know an African-American man
calls the cops and then he's the one that gets in
trouble like that sucks that there's an example
of that whether or not this is Justice which I
don't know uh it does suck there's another example
of that so this case or the case that's going to
happen in five minutes or the time that you know
someone else is assaulted by a cop in the next 36
seconds is uh is shitty and uh I'm I'm sorry you
have to deal with that absolutely uh and finally
uh thank thank you again MC noite seriously and
for you know being patient and and being at least
open to the discourse that we've had here you know
and not being flippant um yeah oh goodness that
chat uh anyway yeah I appreciate you very much
and uh strong with the force closing us out with a
high five appreciate you very much for the sticker
for just showing a little bit of support and for
showing up in the chat today uh guys this has been
a fascinating turn of events I'm sure there will
be more you know details or more discussion and
and whatnot and we have a couple months or like a
month and a half now to wait until they actually
decide what the verdict will be or not the verdict
but like what the sentencing will be so you know
this isn't over yet but it has yeah been a a
a tricky and and difficult topic of discussion
and a and a sad thing to watch unfold certainly
and uh and I think we all wish we lived on the
timeline where this wasn't the case and we didn't
even have to talk about this but uh but yeah he
has been found guilty of two counts uh and again
the The Reckless kind not the premeditated kind
which is you know I think of note certainly and
uh you know we'll just have to wait and see what
the rest of the MCU shapes up into because they
have officially let him go it has been officially
announced uh so yeah we'll see that's all I
can say um but yeah thank you guys for being
here thank you for you know showing your support
sounding off letting us know your opinions and
for the most part being genial and respectful of
each other and of us uh yeah uh goodness gracious
let's go do not this let's go do something else
uh Aisha Kenya Walter chinchilla thank you guys uh
for being here andr sayha uh incredibly goodlook
yug alizer quoting one of my favorite comedies
Zoolander seen that but not Fight Club Brandon P I
love I love Zander but I'm just saying just saying
uh though I finally saw night's stale yeah oh dude
absolutely Bucky thank you for being a part of our
universe and for holding these chats down uh very
much appreciate you uh guys just yeah be good to
each other be good people as dead meat would
say if we don't see you uh before then in live
because we probably won't be saying on every
you know filmed and edited video have a great
holiday whatever you celebrate whatever you don't
celebrate if you don't celebrate anything enjoy
the time off if you celebrate everything enjoy
all that booze uh and if you're sober enjoy all
that time with your family and if your family is
not here enjoy the found family you've made and
have and if you don't particularly like people
enjoy the quiet uh but I I hope you have a good
downtime and I'm very much looking forward to it
myself uh I'm I'm especially aggravated that this
is the time that people think I'm Shilling for
Marvel when I couldn't be matter at them sending
us screeners on the holidays and uh yeah not
thrilled about any of this happening but um we
hope that we at least informed some of the more
uh complicated details the situation and um if
you are someone who is in a horrible environment
and um the this case notwithstanding whether or
not you believe this case went the right way or
the wrong way if you're in a relationship that's
unhealthy and um you should feel safe hopefully
can find a way safely to get out of it and I don't
want people villainizing um this man or this woman
to affect how you perceive men or women of of any
ilk and and uh how you perceive the judicial
process how you perceive how you are are being
treated in life so if you're not being treated
well um get out of that situation however you
can safely and uh if you are the type of person
that was leaving the comments that we were dealing
with therapy because you're probably treating
other people as shitty as as you are treating us
so just you know take care of yourselves uh love
one another and have a great holiday I appreciate
most of you very much yep absolutely thanks guys
be well and uh we'll catch you on the next one
cheers